welcome to this video this is against
the player called circular this German
named ashley with a dutch flag a very
new very new account let's see simulia
this is difficult too difficult to
translate actually it's some chap it's
somewhat like in English lag between a
rock and a hard place this kind of thing
it's not quite quite fitting this this
some way to describe it okay um I don't
want to do d pi FD five is very static
so i'm going to set up a head shot gun
always playing this really really
quickly okay so really you want to put
it on age three that looks and it looks
really ugly now i can go back to me for
cause well then I g5 didn't make any
sense but that's probably true in any
case
Jai one night h3 looks ridiculous
everything so what just went back now i
can trade a couple of times all night d
7 Mary 97 yeah if five is one idea of
the whole setup and I'm going to prepare
a little bit more good thing the queen
is opposed the rook so I go if I've what
he did is he lost a couple of moves have
95 and so on ok let's push coming coming
with the threat of e 4 ok I can take
deform ed 95 something like this Quincy
sex is also a move but it's not
threatening anything okay I'm not
threatening medium important
I'm not sure it should be okay in many
ways but how to determine what's best
trying to take this Bishop them for the
bishop pal okay I don't need to do it
right now though you can start with that
maybe we should be fire then we should
be five was the move that could have
been a nuisance still is maybe okay
let's get rid of this Bishop him and now
I can go 360 pushing and pushing it away
ok so the dark squares are weak now and
really vulnerable Nyjah for is not doing
much though III hangs ok put this on g7
just anticipating yes that he does this
some time here it's probably really
wrong right I mean divorced hanging
really like if i move the night
somewhere I guess neither three though I
was thinking that maybe I can play
Knight h5 night XH 554 check King moves
Queen takes edge for well i know i don't
want to fall too much behind on the
clock
check Joe with night hanks and I want to
pawn a very important one Bishop b5 this
rupee for this was what i was thinking
and I see no great move I'm ready if he
has to retreat the night I go Bishop b5
and this is the best bishop ever only
five like I mean all-star team
MVP in this case if you if we stay with
the sports comparison there seems he
doesn't see anything gay anything grade
yeah I thought would be for simply maybe
maybe that's not that convincing Bishop
b5 of course is always possible yeah
this is also also just good right let's
move tweenage 613 in Queen g6 I mean
that's made on edge to wear my thread
should come in first year anyway always
he able to play with sugars oh wait
Bishop of 1707 Ruby seven but I can go
to GA am there's nothing really
happening my mate comes first and h5
hang so
yeah I can take age 5 which also keeps
everything covered yeah age 6 g 6 and
I'm threatening queena 3m I can take you
from check white resigns yeah he lost a
couple of moves here with this with this
Nyjah 5 business and here blackest
society ok some somehow here g6 Bishop
g7 and he for was really surprising and
he played it very quickly in four
seconds yeah I can even take you for
that this is a strongest actually but I
thought this would be good as well yeah
the best move is Knight f3 after which I
thought that this must be a disaster
which it is strategically but of course
if you can take on e4 and just win-win
material is better yeah I'm just winning
this back here and we need for so is
this much better check and this is a
complete win right yeah there is no no
way for white out of this yeah very
often this this kind of Hedgehog types
setup is a good way to play against
those somewhat tame setups ya like yer
the color or the London and so on
because it keeps all pieces on and you
have some long-term idea this is really
natural fibers just losing time it's not
not really doing anything and this is
the final idea to get it final idea
where that is a point of the set up
learning a t5 in you have an extra pawn
in the center and you can sometimes push
those pieces back they look active but
they're also a little bit clumsily
placed you're running into e5e form and
ideas like that alright thanks for
watching